[Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
Cambly, tu plataforma de aprendizaje
online de inglés con tutores nativos.
Os contamos más detalles en un momento]
Si hablamos de música, hay un estilo que
últimamente destaca por encima de todos los demás:
y no, no me estoy refiriendo al último éxito
de Ariana Grande sino a los tambores de guerra.
La ofensiva en la franja de gaza,
el agotador conflicto en Ucrania,
las múltiples guerras civiles africanas
por aquí y por allá, las escaramuzas de los
hutíes en el mar rojo… Y también los vientos
belicistas que de repente y forma totalmente
inesperada se han desatado en pleno mar caribe.
N1 (7 de diciembre de 2023: El Comando Sur de
EE.UU. inicia ejercicios militares en Guyana en
medio de las tensiones con Venezuela. La Nación)
N2 (28 de diciembre de 2023: Maduro ordena una
"acción conjunta defensiva" en respuesta al envío
de un barco de guerra británico a Guyana. BBC)
N3 (9 de enero de 2024: Pese a las promesas de
no agresión, Maduro volvió a amenazar a Guyana
por el reclamo sobre el Esequibo. InfoBAE)
En diciembre del 2023, el patrullero HMS Trent
de la Armada británica llegó al mar caribe para
realizar tareas relacionadas con la lucha contra
el contrabando y el tráfico humano. Sustituye a su
buque gemelo, el HMS Medway, que estará un periodo
de mantenimiento en el astillero de Gibraltar.
Sin embargo, a finales de mes el HMS Trent
fue desviado con el objetivo de atravesar las
aguas de Guyana en el marco de sus patrullas, lo
que encendió la ira de Caracas… como ya sabéis,
la revolución bolivariana está en plena
cruzada nacionalista con Georgetown por
la disputa territorial que Guyana y
Venezuela mantienen por el Esequibo,
algo de lo ya os hablamos hace poco aquí en VPK.
¿La respuesta chavista? Pues un despliegue que
involucro cerca de 5000 efectivos militares,
así como docenas de navíos y aeronaves militares
en el caribe oriental venezolano:
(1:03 Una acción conjunta de carácter
1:05 defensiva como respuesta a la
1:08 provocación y a la amenaza del Reino
1:10 Unido contra la paz y la soberanía de
1:12 nuestro país.)
A pesar de que el HMS Trent ya
abandonó las aguas en disputa,
los ejercicios y las constantes amenazas
belicistas están comenzando a hacer mucho ruido.
Y aunque un conflicto nos parece hoy por
hoy completamente inverosímil - aunque
visto lo visto últimamente, vete tú a saber - esto
ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos
hagamos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cómo de fuerte es la capacidad militar
de Venezuela? ¿Podrían las fuerzas armadas
bolivarianas sostener realmente un esfuerzo
de invasión y guerra? ¿Cuánta chispa hay
realmente en el brazo armado de la revolución
bolivariana y qué papel juegan las ingentes
compras de armas rusas y chinas que el régimen
chavista ha hecho en las últimas dos décadas?
Pues, amigos, todo esto y más
lo vamos a ver a continuación.
¡Gasolina y arranquemos!
[Pero antes de continuar, dejadme que os pregunte
algo. ¿No os ha pasado que vais por ejemplo de
viaje, o tenéis que hablar con alguien en
el trabajo que solo habla inglés y sentís
inseguridad? A ver, no tenemos que engañarnos,
a todos nos ha pasado alguna vez. Pues veréis,
una de las razones por las que surge
esa inseguridad a la hora de hablar
inglés es por la falta de práctica, por no
estar habituado a hablar con gente nativa.
Pues bien, para solucionar eso está
Cambly. Cambly es una plataforma de
aprendizaje de inglés online. Desde vuestra
propia casa, estés en el país que estés,
podréis hablar con tutores nativos
de varias partes del mundo y con
distintos acentos para olvidar de una vez
por todas vuestros problemas con el inglés.
¿Y sabéis qué es lo mejor? Podéis hacerlo
las 24 horas del día y elegir entre sesiones
particulares o grupales adaptadas
a tu nivel. Chulo, ¿no os parece?
Pues bien, muy atentos a esto. Ahora,
solo por estar viendo este vídeo,
Cambly ofrece un descuentazo del
56 por ciento utilizando el cupón
VISUALCAMBLY2024. Por menos de 10,99
euros al mes, o 219 pesos mexicanos,
tendrás 30 minutos a la semana de clase
con nativos. ¿No os parece una ofertaza?
Pues si queréis quitarle el óxido a
vuestro nivel de inglés y sorprender
a vuestros amigos y compañeros de
trabajo, tenéis el link disponible
aquí debajo en el comentario fijado y
en la descripción. También podéis usar
este código QR que aparece en pantalla.
¡La oferta es solo válida por 72 horas!]
Y ahora sí, continuemos con el poder
militar de la Venezuela bolivariana..
Puede que os sorprende, pero lo cierto es que la
capacidad militar de Venezuela siempre
ha sido por diferentes motivos un tema
caliente en las Américas. Fijaos en
lo que se comentaba ya en los años 50.
(“Venezuela depende de fuentes extranjeras
para prácticamente todo su material militar.
Aunque existe una preferencia por los equipos
estadounidenses, sobre todo los más pesados. Los
jefes militares venezolanos están irritados porque
Estados Unidos no les vende los últimos modelos de
los mejores equipos.” Estimaciones de la CIA sobre
Venezuela – Documentos Desclasificados de 1952)
Así que cuando Washington a partir de los años
60 quiso prevenir la infiltración soviética en
la región para evitar otra revolución al estilo
de la de Cuba, Venezuela se convirtió durante
décadas en el “niño bueno” del team LATAM.
Primero, porque era una democracia, segundo,
porque era un país relativamente rico
en relación con sus vecinos y, tercero,
porque era un importante socio energético.
Así que en cierto modo Estados Unidos pensó
que podría hacer de Venezuela una punta de lanza
contra la influencia soviética en el mar caribe.
Y de hecho, por ejemplo, durante la crisis
de los misiles de Cuba, dos destructores
venezolanos, el ARV Nueva Esparta y el ARV Zulia
participaron en el bloqueo de la isla de Cuba.
(De esta forma, poco a poco Washington contribuyó
a modernizar las fuerzas armadas de Venezuela. Por
ejemplo, permitiéndoles la adquisición en 1983 de
24 aviones de combate F-16, por aquel entonces uno
de los más modernos del mercado. Sí, hace cuatro
décadas Venezuela ya tenía acceso al mismo tipo
de avión que ahora puede llegar a Ucrania.
Por aquella época Venezuela también adquirió
fragatas de clase Lupo, que por aquel
entonces estaban a la vanguardia en
materia de poder de fuego en alta mar)
Son solo dos ejemplos: el dinero del
petróleo y las buenas relaciones con occidente
estaban permitiendo que Venezuela estuviera
poco a poco desarrollando unas fuerzas
armadas pequeñas razonablemente modernas y
funcionales. ¿Para qué? Pues para controlar
el Caribe y también a su vecina Colombia.
Por ejebmplo, el 9 de agosto de 1987 se produjo un
incidente que a punto estuvo de irse de las manos:
una corbeta colombiana, la ARC Caldas, entró
en aguas venezolanas reclamadas por Colombia.
(8:33 En base a la última posición que tengo
8:35 de usted sobre la carta le reitero mi
8:39 invitación a retirarse de aguas
8:42 territoriales venezolanas, repito,
8:46 reitero mi invitación a retirarse en las
8:50 aguas territoriales de la
República de
8:54 Venezuela)
La negativa del buque colombiano terminó
con los flamantes F-16 nuevos preparados
para atacar y con un ultimátum de
Venezuela, que al final Bogotá aceptó.
Claro que toda esta apuesta venezolana cambió
por completo con la llegada de Hugo Chávez al
poder en 1998. Ahí comenzó a ponerse en
marcha el nuevo ejército bolivariano.
Atentos.
(T1: UNA MODERN IZACIÓN COLORADA)
Queridos, amigos y amigas, pese a que
en sus discursos a veces se convertía
en un personaje pintoresco, Hugo Rafael
Chávez Frías era, ante todo, un militar.
(En 2008, Chávez impulsó una reforma de los
reglamentos militares para poder ser un miembro
activo de las Fuerzas Armadas bajo su condición
constitucional de “Comandante en Jefe”; lo que,
por ejemplo, lo habilitaba a utilizar su
uniforme de campaña en actos oficiales,
La vinculación del “Comandante” con las fuerzas
armadas era intensa y ya en 2004 la modernización
de las fuerzas armadas se convirtió en una
prioridad para su gobierno. De esta forma,
el chavismo lanzó hacia 2005 una línea
estratégica conocida como “Fortalecimiento
del Poder Militar”. Esta apuesta consistía en
un ambicioso plan de reequipamiento militar.)
(0:50 La revolución nuestra,
0:52 hay que recordarlo,
0:55 es pacífica pero armada,
no se equivoquen burgueses
1:00 Lo que no le vamos a permitir es que
1:02 incendien nuestro país, tengan la
1:04 seguridad que no lo vamos a
permitir, y no hablo solo por el
1:06 gobierno, hablo por el pueblo, los
1:07 trabajadores, los civiles y los militares)
Claro que algunas cosas ya estaban cambiando.
N4 (16 de mayo de 2006: Bush prohíbe
la venta de armas a Chávez.
Janelle Hironimus, portavoz del
Departamento de Estado, dijo que Venezuela había
forjado estrechas relaciones con Irán y Cuba,
ambos clasificados por Estados Unidos como estados
patrocinadores del terrorismo. The Guardian)
Esta medida tomada por la Casa Blanca fue
un duro golpe para las FFAA venezolanas,
que como ya os hemos contado, tanto
en lo que se refiere a los equipos,
como a los suministros militares, las doctrinas
de defensa o las capacidades de gestión y
mantenimiento, estaban construidas en
torno al equipo militar occidental.
Claro que el Comandante lo que vio fue toda una
oportunidad: el momento perfecto para acabar
precisamente con esa vinculación occidental. Así
que lo que hizo fue tirar de la chequera para
firmar millonarios contratos armamentísticos
con sus dos nuevos socios preferentes.
Rusia y China.
(Tal y como podéis ver en este gráfico,
la modernización de las FFAA venezolanas se dio
en dos tramos, una entre 2006 y 2009, y otra entre
2011 y 2013. En conjunto, las importaciones de
armamento fueron desproporcionadamente más grandes
que en los años anteriores, y principalmente
dependían de pedidos a Rusia y China.
De esta forma, si bien Caracas mantuvo pedidos
a la industria militar de países como Holanda,
Austria y España para el suministro de aviones
ligeros de vigilancia o lanchas de patrullaje
marítimo, el grueso de la relación tuvo que ver
con sus nuevos socios. Con China por ejemplo,
se firmaron multimillonarios contratos
para la compra de uniformes, chalecos,
aviones de entrenamiento, munición de
artillería, helicópteros antisubmarinos
o vehículos antimotines, como es el
caso del Norinco VN4 y Norinco ABV1.
Por su parte, a Moscú, con mucha
diferencia su mayor proveedor,
se le encargó el suministro de sistemas
de misiles, defensas antiaéreas,
helicópteros de combate y más de
100 tanques T-72 modernizados.)
Con todo, el “juguete” preferido de los
militares venezolanos en este período fue
sin duda alguna el Sukhoi Su30MK2; el nuevo
guardián de los cielos de la revolución.
Y es que veréis, el F-16 tiene
sin duda muchas ventajas,
pero con 20 años a sus espaldas y
sobre todo sin ayuda norteamericana
para su mantenimiento y actualización,
seguir contando con ellos era casi
imposible. Así que el gobierno venezolano
se aseguró de recibir 24 de estos aviones.
Y de esta forma, durante la primera década del
siglo XXI, Venezuela logró dar un importante
paso hacia adelante en materia militar… Hay que
decirlo, Chávez se las ingenió para mantener la
ventaja comparativa que Caracas tenía con
sus vecinos. Lo que condujo, por cierto,
a Washington a considerar que sería
recomendable cerrar esa brecha.
(C2 “Rusia se ha convertido en el principal
exportador de armas del gobierno de Chávez.
Entre las compras recientes figuran sistemas
rusos de defensa antiaérea, helicópteros y
cazas Soyuz-30. Venezuela recurre a Rusia por
equilibrio geoestratégico y, en ocasiones,
por necesidad pragmática tras el embargo de armas
impuesto por Estados Unidos en 2006. [...] Si
Venezuela sigue buscando contratos de armas
con Rusia, es concebible que EE.UU. aumente
su ayuda militar a Colombia para preservar la
ventaja militar colombiana.” Venezuela y su
impacto en la estabilidad regional - Centro
de Estudios Estratégicos de La Haya (2009)
(C3 ”Colombia se encuentra en
desventaja estratégica ante
la flota de superioridad aérea
más representativa de la región,
que cuenta con los Su-30 mk 2 rusos (o
cazabombarderos Sukhoi) propiedad de
Venezuela”. Documento de Inteligencia Militar
difundido por la Revista Semana (Marzo 2021)
Y así la revolución bolivariana quedó bastante
bien armada, claro que luego llegó la crisis y
las compras se frenaron en seco. Como diría Milei:
“se acabó la plata”. Eso sí, los “juguetes” que
se habían comprado estaban disponibles y
la revolución no tardó en echarles mano.
Ojo, que esto quizás os va a sorprender.
(T2: COLOMBIA: EL ETERNO CHIVO EXPIATORIO)
Colombia y Venezuela son países hermanos:
lucharon juntas en la guerra de independencia,
y además fueron un único país, La Gran Colombia,
entre 1819 y 1830. Pese a ello, a lo largo de los
años han tenido todo tipo de tiras y aflojas.
Como ya hemos visto, en los 80 s Caracas y
Bogotá estuvieron a punto de acabar en
guerra, fue un conflicto esencialmente
territorial. En los últimos años, sin embargo,
las cosas se pusieron aún más complicadas.
Y es que veréis, en el año 2008, el gobierno de
Colombia, bajo el liderazgo de Álvaro Uribe y con
Juan Manuel Santos como ministro de Defensa,
ordenó la Operación Fénix. Esta operación
consistió en un ataque militar a una base de
las FARC radicada en territorio ecuatoriano.
Esto llevó a que la República del Ecuador,
dirigida en aquel entonces por Rafael Correa,
a denunciar la maniobra como una auténtica
agresión militar contra su país. Estalló así una
crisis que rápidamente escaló a escala regional,
sobre todo cuando Hugo Chávez entró en escena.
(0:40 Esto puede ser el comienzo
de una guerra en Sudamérica
0:43 Porque, si por ejemplo, usted
0:44 se le ocurre hacer eso en Venezuela,
0:46 presidente Uribe, le mando unos Sukhois
0:49 compañero, para que lo sepa)
(0:54 Señor ministro de defensa
0:57 muévame diez batallones
hacia la frontera con
0:59 Colombia, de inmediato.
1:01 Batallones de tanques, la aviación.
1:04 militar que se despliegue
1:07 Nosotros no queremos guerra
1:12 pero no le vamos a permitir al imperio
1:15 norteamericano que es el amo y a su
1:17 cachorro el presidente Uribe, y a la
1:19 oligarquía colombiana, que nos vengan a
1:22 dividir que nos vengan a debilitar.)
La cuestión es que el gobierno colombiano
estaba anunciando la presencia de las FARC
en territorio venezolano y sus vínculos
con ciertos sectores militares venezolanos.
Para colmo e ira de Caracas, el presidente
colombiano Álvaro Uribe firmó un acuerdo
con el presidente Barack Obama, para concretar
el uso de siete bases militares conjuntas para
luchar contra el narcotráfico y el terrorismo.
Algo que Chávez vio como una especie de amenaza.
(1:00 Que no se le ocurre a la
1:03 oligarquía colombiana
1:06 porque se estaría metiendo con los
1:07 soldados de Bolívar y con el pueblo
de Bolívar
+
1:12 Pronto vamos a comenzar a disparar los
1:14 Sukhoi, yo quiero ir al primer disparo,
1:17 a 200 km llega el misil del Sukhoi.)
Y ojo porque el propio Uribe ha reconocido
que los ataques a territorio venezolano
eran una posibilidad bastante real.
(1:00 Yo tenía tres opciones, quedarme
1:02 callado, pero hoy sería difícil presentarme
1:05 ante ustedes, ¿qué tal que yo me hubiera
1:07 quedado callado? La otra opción era un
1:10 operativo militar
en Venezuela… me faltó
1:13 tiempo, me faltó tiempo)
Claro que la cosa no fue a mayores, poco a poco
el tema se fue calmando, siempre quedará la
interrogante de si Hugo Chávez realmente habría
estado dispuesto a emplear su nuevo arsenal
ruso-chino en una guerra abierta contra Colombia,
Sea como sea, la movilización militar venezolana
entre los años 2008 y 2010 fue útil para que
sus fuerzas armadas se prepararan. Digamos
que se aceleraron las prácticas de vuelo,
ejercicios de batalla, los simulacros de tiro,
y todo tipo de maniobras con el nuevo
equipamiento comprado a rusos y chinos.
En otras palabras, que Chávez utilizó la
hipótesis de la guerra para acelerar la
preparación del ejército venezolano. Y aunque
todavía no se han probado esas capacidades,
parece sensato suponer que la
compra de nuevo armamento mejoró,
pese al desastre que es la revolución,
las capacidades militares de Venezuela.
Pero, ¿están realmente preparadas
para una posible invasión de Guyana?
Pues… Atentos.
(T3: ¿PERRO LADRADOR POCO MORDEDOR?)
Según el ranking de GlobalFirePower, Venezuela
ocupa el puesto 52 en cuanto a poder de fuego.
Las Fuerzas Armadas venezolanas tienen 130
mil efectivos y cuentan con 250 aeronaves,
de las cuales 44 son de ataque
y 46 embarcaciones de guerra.
No son unas fuerzas armadas
particularmente grandes. Pero,
¿serían suficientes para hacerse con el Esequibo?
Pensad que desde que dio comienzo la revolución
bolivariana ha pasado ya casi un cuarto
de siglo. Más de 20 años de corruptelas,
amiguismos y enchufismo de todo tipo. Para colmo,
la crisis de los últimos años ha hecho que se
desplome el gasto militar… Lo que, por supuesto,
tiene consecuencias en términos de mantenimiento,
entrenamiento y operatividad.
Pues bien, fijaos cómo a partir
de 2014 se desploma el gasto militar:
N5 (11 de julio de 2023: Aviones de combate
Sukhoi de Venezuela tendrían menos horas de
vuelo que el promedio: expertos. Voz de America)
A esta situación, le tenemos que añadir el hecho
de que gran parte de los equipos rusos que hoy
forman el corazón militar de Venezuela, han
demostrado importantes deficiencias operativas en
el frente ucraniano, por lo que existen múltiples
dudas respecto a su capacidad real de combate.
Por si fuese poco, en los últimos años los
militares venezolanos han asumido muchas
tareas civiles, especialmente las relacionadas
con el funcionamiento de las empresas públicas
y los negocios petroleros. Es decir,
que poco a poco han ido transformando
sus prioridades hasta el punto de que
el rol del “oficial técnico”, es decir,
el efectivo militar profesional enfocado
en los niveles tácticos, está casi extinto.
Y eso no es todo.
Además, desde la modernización venezolana,
sus vecinos Colombia y, sobre todo,
Brasil han hecho grandes avances en lo que
se refiere a sus capacidades militares. Y
no olvidemos que Brasil ya ha venido a
decir que acudiría en apoyo de Guyana.
En otras palabras, teóricamente, sobre la mesa
el ejército venezolano tiene la capacidad de
invadir Guyana y recuperar el Esequibo. Al fin
y al cabo, los 130 mil efectivos militares con
los que cuenta Caracas equivalen al
16% de toda la población de Guyana.
Pero… En realidad, queridos amigos, ha llovido
mucho desde los mejores días de la capacidad
militar bolivariana. Lo más probable es que Guyana
recibiese asistencia militar de Brasil y Estados
Unidos y por pequeña que fue se Venezuela
no parece hoy un actor capaz de resistir.
En otras palabras, quizás nos equivoquemos, pero
no creemos que hoy esa invasión sea hoy por hoy
algo factible. Lo más probable es que el ejército
venezolano se disolviese como un azucarillo.
Sea como sea, esperemos que no tengamos
que comprobarlo. Dicho esto la pregunta es:
¿Qué opinas de las capacidades
militares venezolanas? ¿Crees que
siguen estando a la altura? ¿Cómo crees que se
desempeñaría este país en caso de conflicto?
Déjanos como siempre tus impresiones en los
comentarios y si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle al botón
de like. [Échale también un vistazo a
la promoción tan interesante de Cambly, un 56%
de descuento con el código VISUALCAMBLY2024]
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.